Death by marijuana?
The first report is now on the books -- but
to be honest, it all seems a liiiiittle suspicious.......
[MUSIC]
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for Dnews.
The first reports of a death caused by marijuana
are circulating out of England.
Her name was Gemma Moss, she was 31, and she
reportedly collapsed and died after smoking
a half a joint to help her sleep.
She was ruled by a British pathologist as
well as a coroner to have died from cannabis
poisoning after they found moderate to high
levels of thc in her blood.
They found no other issues with her organs
that could have explained the fatal heart
attack.
Surprised?
I'm no pro at the effects of cannabis on the
body (that would be Trace) but the idea that
someone could die from smoking half a joint
sounds sensational....if not intentionally
misleading.
With almost a week since the news broke, scientists
from around the globe are weighing in calling
the ruling "ridiculous" and "absurd".
A study published in American Scientist, which
built on decades of medical research, found
that in order to overdose on marijuana, you
would need to smoke 1000x the amount that
it takes to get high -- about a third of your
body weight.
Which is why death by marijuana has been declared
virtually impossible by some scientists and
has never been documented before.
Could this be a case of new evidence of the
dangers of marijuana?
Or is it just a politicized report on the
tragic story of a young woman who just happened
to have smoked a joint before her untimely
death?
Scientists at Icahn Medical School in New
York say that the story would be more viable
scientifically if the joint had been laced
with another drug.
But it wasn't.
Psychopharmacologist David Nutt, who has gained
esteem as a no-bs scientist in the world of
international drug policy, says that the report
of "death by marijuana" is dishonest --- and
likely obscuring the true cause of her death.
He suggests it could have been caused by an
underlying cardiac condition that Moss had
without knowing.
It's also known that she was very depressed,
which raises the risk of sudden cardiac arrest.
Dr. Nutt believes it's possible that the small
additional stress on her heart from the joint
may be have been the straw that broke the
camel's back.
He notes that this kind of cardiac attack
has been triggered far more commonly in sports,
having sex, sitting in saunas, even going
to the bathroom.
The jury's still out on what actually happened,
and given that the claim is so extraordinary,
there's certain to be further investigation.
Either way, it's a tragic situation for her
family I'm sure, and I can't imagine it's
much comfort that her death is now caught
up in a controversial battle about the dangers
of marijuana.
What do you guys make of the report?
Let me know down below (on Twitter @DNews)
and we'll be back soon with more science updates!